is your is there nothing else is that it
uh well is that all we have of the news
it's that's good no no i mean i mean the
supreme court expands gun rights well
what about this roe v wade now
oh uh roe v wade roe v
wade have you heard of this apparently
there are women killing their babies
now i'm kidding of course i am
pro-choice kill them all kill the moms
great line in the bird cage when nathan
lane goes i say kill the mother and i
know what you're saying well the baby
will die also but it's going to die
anyway let it go down with the ship
um
roe v now here's the deal
they're pre-recorded we're pre-recording
this episode so i want everybody to know
that this roe v wade thing is is coming
out in a few days
so i'm going to do two reactions to this
just pick the one that happened
okay
oh my god they overturned roe v wade
that's [ __ ] up
women and poor people and [ __ ]
roe v wade was not overturned
interesting many thought it would have
been
[Laughter]
those are the two reactions depending on
which way this news goes
fill in which i'm unaffected by roe v
wade i think
within a certain window you can have the
abortion but afterwards it gets a little
creepy when it starts to look like a
little puppy in there i don't want you
to just fillet it and take its head off
now again i'm unaffected by it because i
find women to be repulsive but
that not all of them i'm kidding many of
them that pay me i think are great and
there's a few of them that i enjoy
condoleezza rice she's a real uh fun one
now
this roe v wade thing that either was
overturned or it wasn't
what is this
we're trying to have a nice time it's
the fourth of july
whitney cummings is staying at my house
i told her it smells like paint she said
she prefers it
now
what so now can you get any information
yeah so i mean it's it's up in the air
right now but it would be a judicial
earthquake but it's been it's been
decided already
you gotta remember that's been decided
so
my i'm asking you what is your opinion
on the decision
my opinion on the decision is i think
it's messed up that it got overturned
and that it's gonna go to the states you
think it is gonna be overturned yeah and
i think you know you're gonna have to
choose i'm gonna do one for both where
you don't know which it is ready okay
this is an inherently complex issue and
there are very uh heartfelt
strongly held opinions on either side
that's true thank you
now that will work no matter what
happens yeah yeah because i don't know
what's gonna happen but it's gonna
happen soon they say
by the time this comes out roe v wade
will either be the law of the land or it
will be overturned what an odd week to
pre-record
now
what makes this interesting is i don't
care
now i do care
a little
because i think women should be able to
get abortions like in the beginning
ish
like in the beginning up until a certain
point
then it gets a little uncomfortable but
late term if like
if if it's gonna be a baby that's born
without like
like if it's gonna be like a baby that's
born like
where it doesn't have like all the
hearts on the outside of the body or it
can't live
you know words like a gypsy there is i
understand that's a joke
don't curse me curse him no no
now i'm saying that uh
i'm just saying that there's
late in life
there are
i mean late in the pregnancy
there are things that happen
and sometimes the the
the baby needs to get harpooned
and
i i'm not involved with it
now
my position on this has always been this
hey
is there any more dip
i
my position on this has always been
because people get very
they go nuts with this they start
screaming yelling and i always go like
this i go what you buy this for
you know my position on roe v wade has
always been
is this a legal two family
you could do rental if you wanted in the
back
my position on roe v wade has always
been the parking's not as bad as i
thought
i thought that the parking would be bad
it's not that bad
position on roe v wade has been very
much like well when you do the kitchen
you do the whole thing you know just go
in there and do it
porcelain tile is fine it's durable and
it looks like marble
these are the opinions
that i've had over the years with regard
to roe v wayne
um and of course i'm for women getting
abortions and i think the government
should fund it up until the point where
it makes me personally uncomfortable
you know because it there is a certain
now what's weird about this is i guess
it's already been decided
by the time this comes out but i i'm
preparing everyone for all of the
there's all of the things here you have
all of my reactions
to this
[ __ ]
whoa
now
i don't know what to tell you but let's
move on here from that because that's
the our roe v wait section and it's very
important
now
it is because people you know it's i
don't know but you gotta
you gotta it's one of those where it's
like hey
you know
it's one of those where you go god damn
it
ask me about roe v wade right now
uh like in the future like where i'll be
my father i look like my father right
now ask me about roving wayne see they
might overturn roe v wade i mean every
day
my boomer father's response ask me about
rovi with my boomer fathers response
yeah they
did you see the roe v wade news
yeah they would overturn it you know so
i was just saying that you know
i was just saying that someone was
someone was saying that and i was saying
that you know
it's just one of those things
i don't i don't know if my dad knows
what roe v wade is he probably does
i don't know if he knows what roe v wade
is